this is a production of Cornell
University hello everyone my name is
keny Rodriguez and today we're going to
talk about harvesting watermelon I'm
here with Steve reers he's a
Horticultural specialist and today um I
want to ask you some questions Steve and
mainly about watermelon so sometimes we
have the watermelon in our field and we
know it's big but we are not sure when
is the right time to harvest so if you
can talk us a little bit about that okay
I'd be happy to yeah watermelon I think
uh for some people they think a
watermelon is something that you can
only grow deep in the South where you
got a long growing season and you're
going to get a 20 or 30 lb fruit but we
have some beautiful uh small we call ice
box melons here that are just perfect
for a small family or one or two people
question is how do you know when this is
right because if you harvest it too
early you're going to get a very very
Bland type of flavor in there as well
and of course if you leave it on too
long it can start to develop cracks and
it can actually start to break down so
so when do you do this well if we were a
commercial grower I'd have a little
thing called a refractometer and I'd put
it in there um and a few fruit and get
an idea of how much the sugars are but a
home Gardener is not going to do that so
there's a couple of things that I look
for one is we always talk about a
tendril on a watermelon and you can see
here here's a tendril and it's similar
to what peas have and it helps them
climb on things and we always say when
that tendal that's closest to the melon
which would be this one when that starts
to Brown that's usually a good sign that
this is getting pretty close and then
the other thing that I like to look for
is the bottom what we call the ground
spot and you can see how this one is
still kind of yellowish and green in
color when this starts to turn almost an
ivory or whitish color that's also
another good sign that this one is going
to be probably ready to harvest some
people will swear by knocking on it I've
never been able to uh make that work for
me but if you think it does it makes a
different sound feel free to to try but
I look for the tendril and I look for
that ground spot that starts to turn
color I think this one is probably at
least four or 5 days away before we'd
Harvest that okay I also have seen that
the fruit is very small but also we have
some me shaping watermelon why do you
think that is or why do that happen yeah
it all goes back to pollination probably
so uh we'll show some pictures here of
the different flowers but we need bees
to pollinate the flowers and if enough
pollen comes over to the flow that we
can get fruit set but maybe not enough
to get the full size that we'd want we
can sometimes get a fruit that might be
a little bit smaller than what we
expected or it can be misshapen and
that's usually an indication that you
know not enough pollen moved over um to
the female flower to make the a really
big fruit that is what we were hoping
for and what happened for example yeah I
know went to harvest and I followed all
the instructions that we were given we
know that we had good pollination but
what happened if the watermelon doesn't
taste as good as I was expecting it to
taste right if that's the case um you
could have harvested at the wrong time
it might have been a little bit too
anxious to harvest but it's also a lot
of it is the season and if you have a
cool rainy season um you don't have the
sunlight and you don't have the
photosynthe so you don't have the sugars
going into the fruit that's going to
lead to a bland melon and if I um
irrigating the watermelon is there a
time where I should stop um irrigating
foret that's a good question because
what you want to do like what we see
right here for this watermelon which is
probably just as I said within a week of
harvest this is when you want to turn
the irrigation off of course here in the
Northeast it rains a lot we really can't
always control it but I would not be
irrigating this this melon at all this
is we wanted to sort of concentrate
those sugars and that will make things
sweeter and what do we do whenever we
Harvest it like how do I storage it or
what is the right time of is there a
right time of the day to harvest it
usually the morning is probably the best
time time to harvest it because at that
point it's still cool um if we Harvest
it late in the day it's already picked
up all the heat from the Sun and then
what you're going to be battling that
then you're taking this you're putting
it into a refrigerator has to cool down
and all that time when that is 80 or 90°
you can think about once you harvest it
all those sugars start to respire so you
want to start with a cool with with a
cool in the morning and then put it
right in the refrigerator surprisingly
um you can these store really well I've
seen store up to 2 to 3 weeks in a
watermelon before they're cut so you can
you can keep them in there for a long
time so hopefully this advises will help
you to know when to harvest the
watermelon and you will get the sweetest
as you can watermelons but thank you so
much steeve for this advices I think
this will surely help everyone to know
when is the right time to harvest
them this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu